when you imagine a playground chances
are it looks something like this
there's usually a slide a bridge and a
high point with a domed roof
that's what makes this a playground and
this
and this but what about this this isn't
a junkyard
it's called an adventure playground here
there are no plastic play structures
just things like old tires wood planks
and hammers and nails
places like this represent one of the
most debated ideas in play architecture
that playgrounds should be designed to
let kids take more risks
now this nightmare for helicopter
parents is the hottest new thing in
american playgrounds
because there's growing evidence that
play like this is
a whole lot healthier and safer for kids
[Music]
they can play with very dangerous tools
they can take really dangerous risks and
overcome them
and this builds up a tremendous sense of
self-confidence in themselves
which is really quite fascinating to
watch that's marjorie allen she was a
british landscape architect and
children's welfare advocate around the
middle of the century
in 1945 she visited copenhagen where she
met an architect named carl theodore
sorensen
two years earlier during the german
occupation of denmark sorensen noticed a
problem
kids in his neighborhood weren't using
playgrounds in fact they were playing
just about everywhere else
even in construction sites and bombed
out buildings so in a housing
development in the suburbs of copenhagen
sorensen closed off an empty lot and
filled it with building materials
discarded objects
and tools here kids could dig and build
and invent
on their own the play structures were
ultimately designed by the kids
themselves
sorensen called it a junk playground and
kids and parents
loved it when she returned to england
marjory allen started opening similar
playgrounds all across london
and she renamed them from junk to
adventure
from there they became a global
phenomenon they spread to minneapolis
boston toronto tokyo houston berkeley
berlin
and to create these playgrounds
designers had to introduce a critical
element
controlled risk in this context a risk
isn't the same thing as
a hazard when you're climbing a tall
tree a rotten branch is a hazard the
threat is unexpected
but how high you climb is a risk it's
manageable and requires you to actively
make a decision
you can break the elements of controlled
risk down into six categories
heights speed tools dangerous elements
rough and tumble play and the ability to
disappear or become lost
and a good adventure playground includes
a mix of these
designers also focus on separation of
space to give kids the feeling of
discovering things on their own
parents have to stay out that can mean
installing a physical barrier
or providing things like restrooms cafes
and seating
so that parental experience isn't an
afterthought finally designers fill it
with loose parts
these are the manipulatable objects the
planks barrels
bricks and tools that fuel risky play
the idea behind all these design
elements is that kids respond well to
being treated seriously
if they're presented with risky items
with a serious functional purpose
they'll respond cautiously and conduct
more experimentation
but if presented with an overly safe
static space they often wind up seeking
dangerous thrills that the built
environment fails to provide
which can result in higher injury rates
than risky play at adventure playgrounds
in the us a culture of lawsuit-proof
playscape design means that overly safe
playgrounds are the norm
and design philosophy is focused on how
to reduce height movement and hard
materials
and that hasn't made playgrounds better
when marjorie allen visited american
playgrounds in 1965
she called them an administrator's
heaven and a child's hell
but adventure playgrounds have recently
begun to catch on in the u.s
perhaps due to an effort to introduce
more unstructured play
and their construction comes with a fair
share of criticism
now making kids play with hammers and
nails that's not adventure
it's just work they're tricking kids
into building their own playground
adventure playgrounds do have downsides
they're pretty ugly
they require a lot of space and they
need resources to staff
and maintain and as with any playground
there is an opportunity for injury
but the underlying philosophy of risky
play can help kids
live better lives for one thing riskier
playgrounds encourage more activity
a study comparing playgrounds in london
where risky play spaces are popular
to those in san francisco los angeles
and new york
found that children using london's
playgrounds were up to 18 percent more
physically active
the london playgrounds were cheaper and
boasted fewer injuries too
and multiple studies have shown that
children who engage in risky play have
better risk detection
creativity and self-esteem
the playground is one of the only kinds
of architecture designed specifically
for children
and if the standard model we've decided
on is seen as boring by its users
that's a problem better design can fix
that
even if it's a little risky
i had to look through so many pictures
of playgrounds for this story that i
decided to use wix
to create a website collecting all of
the ugliest and saddest
pictures of playgrounds that i could
find and now i have a perfectly
curated arrangement of pictures of
playgrounds next to graveyards
and slides leading into dumpsters
and whatever these kid-friendly statues
are if you're looking for a simple way
to share your passion about broken
infrastructure or whatever it is that
you're into these days
you should absolutely head to wix to
create your own website just like this
click the link below wix does not
directly impact our editorial but
their support makes videos like this
possible so
check them out